with the frigid weather in much of the
country this week you may be longing for
an escape I know I am and it looks like
many Americans are already planning one
travel bookings are way up in the New
Year and you may be surprised to hear
just where people are headed and how
little some are paying to get there here
to tell us all about it is CBS News
travel editor Peter Greenberg good
morning mr. Greenberg good morning mr.
mayor
take me away mr. Greenberg well our way
let's start with Portugal because I like
this idea I know you do well you know
everybody's like enamored with Spain and
France because they're all failed our
history majors they gotta go see the
painting studies yeah see and then they
come out of the loop and they go oh it's
so small but bottom line is high
standard of living low cost of living in
Portugal yes it's really come back it's
no longer the kingdom of a dead empire
imagine this 15 new hotels being built
there right now in opening seven
restaurants that have already gotten
Michelin stars this year alone right and
then there's the Azores people who
forget about the Azores any have nonstop
service from New York the cool thing
though c.a.p the airline of Portugal
they'll fly to Lisbon you'd be a
five-night stopover there and then fly
you on to any one of 65 destinations
they fly to in Europe or Africa for the
same price so it's a great deal that is
a great deal speaking of other Goodyear
deals Malta yeah you know what you don't
have to go to Italy go to Malta it's
only a two-hour flight from Rome that
looks really nice it is really nice and
this year filete of the capital has been
named the UNESCO World Heritage City of
Culture for 2018 so it's really coming
alive medieval history here every world
power at one point tried to govern Malta
even Napoleon Hill hung out there go to
the island of Gozo they make the most
incredible olive oil and you bring it
home I like oil one of the hottest
destinations last year was Iceland but
you're recommending an alternative the
Faroe Islands I'm gonna give you two for
today because the way you get to the
Faroe Islands is you got to go through
Iceland uh-huh it's midway between let's
say the Norwegian Sea in the in the end
the North Atlantic sounds cold it's this
time of the year yes but you plan for
summer where you got 22 hours of
daylight every day imagine 18 Islands 17
of which are connected by underground
road tunnels and it's your smallest
capital only 20,000 people even have
their own Symphony Orchestra great food
great fishing and great history all
right
moving on to another non-traditional
getaway she lay yeah this little string
being of a country that's what it is a
long string being of a country has an
incredible coastline it's got the driest
desert in the world the Atacama it's got
the fjords it's got the Andes it's got
everything and it's very accessible and
use it as a hub in Santiago to go all
the way out to Easter Island
let's leave South America and go north
to Mexico Baja California which is
actually not in the US no it's not the
us strange enough but the cool thing
about it is it is in North America and
what's great about Baja you're dealing
with hundreds and hundreds of miles of
great coastline it's all drivable but
the big secret is the wine their wine
production is so cool and the quality of
their wine is so cool that little known
fact 75% of their product is exported to
France what do the French know that you
don't know take the wine tour find out I
went to Baja and I imbibed a lot of
tequila but I'll have to go back for the
wine okay okay
Detroit Michigan why is this on the list
P Motor City is back after decades of
neglect they've come back they've
they've restored all the buildings they
restored all the parks there's a great
restaurant seen along the river yes
they've got a great baseball team and
talk about their football team but they
are really coming back in a big way one
last one and this is the one I have to
say surprise me York Pennsylvania
it is great American history they're
from the Revolutionary War to the Civil
War and great food scene great gallery
scene and if you take your kids and you
ask them where does food come from and
they tell you the store take them to
York Pennsylvania because it's the
factory tour capital of the world
you get to see how things are actually
made from from motorcycles to potato
chips york peppermint pattie came from
York say you had to say that yes but
it's no longer made there I'm sorry I'm
sad but potato chips yes you win some
you lose some Peter Greenberg always
good to see you you got
thank you